you know what you said before about
adele losing the weight like she was
like the post child for the larger pot
artist and then she lost the weight and
everyone's like
that that's what's better for her but
then she's kind of lost the symbol of
what she used to represent
so i i think it
would be hard for her to deny her kids
to be even though i think she should
have it'd be hard for her to deny it i
guess to do that so let's let's go
through a couple of the things that
happened yeah go on okay so the first
thing that happened yeah was can't kanye
doesn't want his ki his daughter on
tick-tock i agree you agree 100
do you think
he
it's weird that he's saying he doesn't
want his daughter on tick-tock when
he was cool with his daughter like going
on stage with like a mic
and like performing
for his like clothing brand
i think because if it's safety of the
child isn't that like putting the kid i
think it's more
at least
on stage with him
he's in control of
how she comes across or what she's
putting out but on tick tock
he's not so it
he's not con
he can't um
regulate what she puts out
whereas her coming on stage with him
it's a different kind of
vibe because especially on tick tock
like
a lot of
a lot of girls young girls
are
to some extent
set selling sexuality
and that's the last thing any father
wants for his daughter because her
coming on stage is being like oh she can
perform with me look how talented she is
but her being on tick tock like she's
putting some red like some weird makeup
on and what was the what was the quote
something like i know what now what was
it
um i don't remember actually i can look
it up uh what was it she said but she
was like that was more airing on setting
sexuality and she's how old is she like
seven or eight well i think okay because
i think of this from the like the
perspective
yeah that's trash behavior the well i
don't i didn't i looked at the tick tock
i didn't think it was that bad too far
i've not seen it it just looked like a
kid with like a bunch of makeup on like
singing to a sound
but
like you never played like i played
around with makeup when i was a kid
yeah but were you like flaunting
yourself to like everyone
with it no
but this is this is what i think of the
equivalent go on so
you and i we have a child okay yeah boom
divorce awful i hate each other god do i
lose everything are you taking all my
[ __ ] off yeah
should have done that for you but so i'm
out here in my apartment i want the kid
to like come on my youtube show
yeah that because that's what i do and
that's like a bonding time for the kid
yep do you i don't i don't really think
i'd tell you like i tell you to go to
hell if you said he can't be on my show
but so here's the thing though i think
if i'm because she's monitoring the tick
tock so if i'm monitoring it because she
the kim runs the account so i tell you
what it's about the it's about the
respect of him as a father giving
permission yeah so like i don't know
what it's like in the states but in this
country
if the parents aren't together
but one of the parents wants to take the
child on holiday they need permission
from the other parent otherwise they
legally can't do it legally they can't
do it because they could be running away
with the child right
so
and
and because of the potential dangers of
what social media can do and how
exposing it can be
i completely agree it should have the
same principle of okay if you've got a
minor
like you need permission from both
parents
for for them to go on
and kanye was not giving permission like
he was like no i disagree yet she did it
anyway
so
um
in that sense i'd be like nah i like
also the other thing i was going to say
when she came on stage
with him
right
like
i don't think she was wearing makeup
like not like that
and one thing jordan peterson says
he was like
wearing makeup is sexual signaling yeah
so why is she wearing makeup why is she
sexual signaling on tick tock of course
he's going to be against that like i
said that's selling sexuality well
i
i do see that like that point of view i
do and i i could like i could understand
that but sometimes it just felt like a
little bit to me yeah and genuine and
more of like a control thing when like
magically like now when she's dating
pete you have a problem with this it's
just like but but so do you think if
they were still together he would be
fine with her being on tick-tock yeah
but was she on tick-tock when they were
to get together that's a good question i
don't know
probably not maybe not otherwise there
wouldn't be this much heat would there
but he wasn't even there i thought
because i thought he was living in
wyoming
i don't know but it didn't happen though
no you're right because okay here's the
thing right if they if if
if kanye and kim were together right
and
she was like oh yeah why don't what's
there kid's name blue no
that's daisy's north north right yeah
and kim was like on you know i want to
put north on tick tock weather and he
was like no i don't want you to because
they were together i think kim would
have respected his wishes
but now they're not together she's not
respecting his wishes which i disagree
because he's still the father of the
child yeah
but then that's kind of a sticky thing
in divorce because like
who gets to pick
is it always the flight who gets to pick
what like right i mean right now the
courts favor the mother right yeah so so
that's not necessarily fair but if we
were gonna like reconstruct the court
system let's just say yeah mom wants one
thing dad wants another it doesn't even
have to be tick-tock it could be where
they go to school where whatever yeah
how do you pick
well i would say
i would say um something like where did
they go to school it would it would just
make sense
that
so if the child's with the mother
to go to the school that is
um more convenient
for them like so if there's a school 10
minutes around the corner the father's
like no i want her to go to this one
which is two hours away that's silly
right but i think it's different when
it's like
something that can have
um
age restrictions on it
you need permission from both i think so
like so would you if kim said i don't
want my daughter on stage like i don't
think that's a good environment for a
child would you agree with that
would i agree like would you say like
then like he can't bring her on stage
yeah i would if she didn't want her on
stage yeah and he did yeah
and she was like no don't i'd like well
then you don't do it okay
i just like kim kardashian why do you
love her so much
okay okay why do you love this i like
her for the same reason i like donald
trump i like her for the same reason i
like kylie jenner
which is what i like people
that
do things that everybody says that they
can't
so kim kardashian everyone called her a
hoe right and she said okay
call me a hoe no talent whatever
i'm gonna marry the greatest rapper of
all time get a proposal from him
and chris humphrey who's like i forgot
what he did but i didn't [ __ ] i didn't
even know who he is he's he did
something and so i was like i like
people that do something that everyone
says they can't
i respect that and then that the same
thing everyone says you have no talent
whatever okay whatever i'm gonna become
a billionaire like that's some boss [ __ ]
that's some boss [ __ ] i